mesdames et messieurs du futur, il est
temps de me présenter, j'utiliserai les
mêmes mots que dr.  West mon nom est Mark
Jarvis et je suis le premier homme à être
ressuscité pour résumer c'est ce que je
suis 20% restes d'organes vitaux et de
tissus récupérés de mon ancien corps principalement
le cerveau et le reste du système
nerveux central
65%  os clonés muscle peau
terminaisons nerveuses et autres organes 10%
implants bioniques pour renforcer le
système musculo-squelettique et les
organes sensoriels et 5% technologie interne
conçue pour contrôler le
bon fonctionnement de l'organisme en
plus de cela ajouter un système de
connexion externe un ombilical détachable  cordon
enira moyen constant de me connecter à
ma nouvelle mère mécanique dr.  West et
son équipe ont dû faire face à d'innombrables
problèmes depuis le temps de la réanimation et
leurs solutions respectives ont été
insupportables.
ainsi
de suite et ainsi de suite et ainsi de suite tout cela
résultant en un organisme terriblement fragile en
permanence au bord de l'effondrement
l'homme de laboratoire
le monstre de Frankenstein
[Musique]
il y a une autre façon de voir les choses
j'allais mourir j'allais disparaître à
jamais et  Je suis vivant à nouveau Je suis vivant
Je suis vivant
[Musique]
avant de mourir Je pensais qu'il n'y avait
rien après la mort
mais le meilleur était encore à
venir  et messieurs du futur je
m'appelle Mark Jarvis et je suis le premier
homme moyen à
ressusciter c'est un pas de géant dans l'histoire de la
médecine je me demande ce qui va se passer à partir de
maintenant si je  'sera toujours normal nous l'appelons
esprit écrivain si vous le connectez à votre
tête, vous pouvez enregistrer vos pensées si j'ai
réussi à enregistrer mes souvenirs bien ils
m'appartiennent toujours
quand vous vous débarrassez de tout ce que vous
étiez ce qui reste
[Musique]
I  j'allais mourir
j'allais disparaître pour toujours
et je revis
je suis vivant ces souvenirs ne sont pas
effacés mais tu penses que te réanimer
serait un miracle j'ai peur
qu'on ne puisse rien faire
je ne crois pas  toi
je ne crois pas que tu t'es jamais vraiment soucié
de mes papiers tu as choisi d'arrêter de vivre
pour qu'il puisse avoir une autre vie
tu te trompes
c'est le monde dont j'ai toujours rêvé